foreign
YouTube channel in this session we will
learn what is web scraping then we will
see whether it is legal to escape data
from web pages or not further we will
have Hands-On demonstration to scrape
data from Simply learn web page but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update before starting
I want to ask you is web scraping legal
or not you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer as yes or no in the
comment section or if you want to
comment something about it surely do we
can have a discussion over the comment
now let's learn what is web scripting
web scraping is extracting unstructured
data from web pages and store it in a
structured form
let's see whether it is legal or not to
scrape data from websites
depending on the website web scraping
may be permitted or prohibited you can
check a website's robots.txt file to see
if web scripting is permitted or not
you can locate the file by adding
slash robots.txt to the URL you intend
to script I will be scraping data from
Simply non webpage the URL for the
robots.txt file will be
HTTP colon slash slash
www.simpleon.com slash robots.txt
and to scrape a website you can either
use web API or do HTML web scripting
using tools as you will perform now
so for that
first we will create a folder
and name it as
peps creeping
using python
and inside
we will open the command prompt
and write the command code space
period and press enter
it will open the editor and I am using
the visual studio code if you want to
use any other item you can
now
we will name the file as
Fab s dot py
now to start with the code first we will
install python packages we don't have to
write new code for everything we can use
existing code written by experts for
that we'll install three packages that
would be requests bs4 and HTML 5 lib
for that we will visit the command
prompt again
and write the commands to install the
packages
the first package we will install is
requests
and press enter
you can see that it states the
requirement is already satisfied as I
have already installed the package you
will just write the command and press
enter and the package will be installed
in your system
now for the second package we will write
the command
pip install
bs4
that is the beautiful soup package you
can see that here it also states that
the requirement is already satisfied
I have already installed the package
you can just write the command and press
enter and the work would be done for you
now we'll install the next package that
is HTML5 live for that we will write the
command pep install html5lib
and press enter
as I also installed this package so it
states the requirement is already
satisfied
and if you face any issues while
installing any of the packages just
command down in the section and we will
get back to you and help you install
those packages
and when you run the code for web
scripting
like we didn't understand the basic
principles of web scripting so when you
would be running the code for web
scraping a request is sent to the URL
that you have mentioned as a response to
the request the server sends the data
and allows you to read the HTML or XML
page the code then parses the HTML or
XML page and finds the data and extracts
it for you
now to extract data using web pages
you need to follow some basic steps
first you need to find the url that you
want to scrape and inspect the page
you can just go to the developer options
or just click the right click on any div
or on any part of the web page you will
find the inspect at the bottom of the
right click and you can just see the
HTML content there
and then find the data you want to
extract then write the code
for what you want to extract
run the code and store the data in any
required format
so now we'll start
but before starting first you will visit
the website we want to
scrape the data
so this is the website that is
www.simplant.com
and
we'll just see it's
source file you can see the code here
that is HTML in the JavaScript code here
moving on to our view Studio code
we will start
with a code to extract the data to
scrape the data from the web page
so first thing we will do is import the
request
and why we should do that like we must
obtain the HTML as a string to work with
so with the help of the request module
get function can quickly obtain the HTML
data and for that we will install the
sorry import the request module for that
we'll write the command
import
requests
and then we will import the beautiful
soup class from PS4
so for that we'll write the command from
bs4
import beautiful soup
and now
we can start with a code as we have
imported the packages
so first thing we will write the URL for
the web page we want to extract the data
and scrape the data
we'll just
name the variable as URL only
and inside we will just copy the
link
from the browser on here
so we'll copy the link
and move back to either
and paste it here
so this is the website we want to scrape
the data
now we'll make a variable product tree
write the link in get function to get
the HTML data as a string
for that
we will create a variable
and name it as r
we are naming it as our as in the
documentation of request module uh they
are they have also taken the variable
we are just clicking it
as it is
so we'll use the get function with that
we write the command requests
dot get
and inside will pass the URL we want to
scrape the data
and in next line we will
use the variable HTML content
and side we will store our DOT content
that is
it will get all the data stored in the
HTML content variable so now we will
print it
so that will write the command print
inside
let me just pass the variable print
content
and now we will save the file
and run the file
you can see that all the data that we
have just seen in the source file has
been extracted
and it is showing an abdominal
so if you just see the source file you
can see that all the data has been
scraped and it's in our terminal
so once the HTML is fetched using the
request the next step will be to pass
the HTML content for that we'll use
Python's beautiful soup module which
will create a tree like structure for
that document object model that is done
for that
we will write the command and create a
variable soup
and we will use beautiful soup
and inside will pass two arguments one
is our HTML content another is our
parcel
for that we will write the command r dot
content
comma
and next rule
uh pass HTML parcel
for that we will write HTML dot parser
now we will just run a loop to scrape
all the code from the web page and
before that we will just comment the
download print command
so we shouldn't be confused with this
output
and the next print statement we would be
just commanding so we won't get
confused so we will also delete the
output from the terminal
and get the new terminal
so we have the fresh one
and now we
make a command
so for that we will just run a group
and we'll use finder function
it's used to find any of the element or
tag from the old web page content
so here we'll find the code
the whole code from the web page
where we will get it printed
I will save the file
and run it
okay so this is okay
place the polar
you can see that the file has run
successfully so it has scraped the data
now will it starts scraping the real
data and get it at output in the
terminal
so for that first we'll scrape the title
of the web page
for that we'll write the command and
use the variable
to enter only
titles
and that would be equal to
soup dot title
and we will get it printed
so first world
let's titles the variable
and
we will get this for Loop in comment
section so
it won't be able to run again and again
and we'll get our terminal clean so we
can just see the output for the
particular command and don't get
confused as there would be a lot more
data when we scrape the data from a web
page so it would be easy for us
to understand and learn the commands and
the output
so now I will save the file
and run it
as you can see the title from the web
page of simplina it's simply done online
courses
bootcamp certifications platform
so now
if you
want to get this only string
for that you can
just write down DOT string
with the variable
save the file
and run the file and get the output
you can see that the title tag has been
removed and the simple string has been
at our output
so moving on
now we will use the find function
so what is it meant for
so it is used to get the first element
in the HTML page as we have a web page
that is simpleon.com so
we will start with paragraphs
so we'll pass
P tag that is the paragraph tag in the
find function so it will get us the
first paragraph from the whole web page
so for that we will write the command
print
and it's whole because of the soup
so soup Dot
the find function
and inside we will pass the paragraph
text
no we will just comment down
and clear terminal
save the file
and now we'll run it
you can see that it has printed the
first paragraph that is partnering with
world's leading universities and so on
so
now we have the second function that is
find all it will give the output of all
the elements you just want to get it
past them
so we'll do the same with the paragraph
only and use the final function and get
all the paragraphs from a web page that
is simplylearn.com
for that we will write the command
and we'll
get it commented so we won't just
confuse with all the commands and the
output
so the function name is find underscore
all and inside will pass the paragraph
tag only
we will save the file
first clear the terminal
and run it
you can see that all the paragraphs
paragraphs from the web page have been
printed
now
if you want all the paragraphs line by
line
we can also use the loop for that
for that
we will just
get it stored
in a variable that would be a
equal to
soup dot final p
and
now we will run the group
foreign
so
we won't get confused
save the file
and run it
you can see all the paragraph
have been printed in our terminal
now if you want to scrap class of any
element
if we can do that by just writing the
class
addition to a command that is find and
the attribute you want to pass in that
as you can see that these paragraph tags
have classes
so we will find the class of the first
paragraph
put that to write the command print
so don't find and find it used to scrape
the data
and that is the first one of the and the
element
right
and it would be skipping for the
paragraph and we want to get the class
for that
for that
we'll just initiate the script brackets
and write class in it
and I will save the file
clear the terminal
and first we have to comment it down
so it didn't get printed
so yeah
so as you can see that it has written
key error class so the first paragraph
doesn't have any class as we have seen
in the previous output that some
paragraphs have class but here it's
showing that key error class the first
paragraph don't have any
and similarly we can find the ID
and as I remember
those
no ID also but for the syntax part
this is a Syntax for that you just have
to write ID in the square brackets
we will save it
and
comment on this command
now save it clear the terminal
and run the file
foreign
that is key error ID so there is no ID
assigned to the first paragraph and if
you want to get uh the ID of any element
you can just use this command and the
element tag should be here we have just
find out for the first paragraph
if you want to scrape only text from the
paragraph
that is only text and note the paragraph
tags in the output
so for that write the command first
we'll comment it down
and comment the previous commands and
now
get the text the function is get
underscore text
so for that we'll write the command
print
so dot
find
uh we will do it for the first paragraph
only
find p
dot get underscore text
oh
yeah don't get underscore text so this
is the command
uh from this you will get the output of
the text only that is stored in the
paragraph tag so we will save the file
clear the terminal
and run the file
as you can see that we have code output
that is partnering with world's leading
universities and so on that goes our
first paragraph and there is no
paragraph tag here
and you can do the same four whole code
uh for that you can
write a simple command
just write print
get underscore text
it will give you all the text from the
web page of simpleline.com so first we
will clear the terminal
save the file
external the file
you can see in the terminal that it has
given us
all the text from the web page
and with no tags
there is not a single tag for any of the
element
so now moving on now we'll see the
anchor tags from the web page
so first we'll
get this command in the comment
so we will use the final function for
the anchor tag also and get all the
anchor tags printed
so
get a variable and name it as anchor
and
write a command soup dot find all
and inside we will pass the element and
that would be the tag of that element
that is Anchor
and it tag is a
and we will get it printed
so I will save the file clear the
terminal
and run the file
foreign
that
the anchor text have been printed
from the whole web page
so now if you want to get in in a pretty
manner you can just run a loop and get
all the anchor attacks
in lines
so
we'll get all the anchor text but anchor
tags have text in them
so links are in href and HRA feature
variable written in the tag so we will
use the splicing for that
we will run a loop
s
and print
[Music]
I
just have brackets
get the href
so you can just get all the anchor text
printed
and save the file
and get this commented
that would be an anchor only
run it
okay okay uh over there so first we'll
clear the terminal so we don't get
confused with the previous output
and now we have you know a and
we can anchor
you can't
I don't get
image here and it shouldn't be
the square brackets now
I'm going to save it
and run the file
so you can see that all the links have
been printed and in the line
so as I have told you earlier that
anchor tags have href in them links they
are in the hrf and hrf is a variable and
that is we have used here that is we
have inserted href inside the get
function and code all the links that are
present in the web page
now we will create a set and store all
the links in it
and you know the probability of set that
it counts the item for a single time if
there is a repetition of those items
for that
comment it
so there's a command that is find only
and now
we will get all the anchor tags
in a set
for that
and we will get the variable all
right and
initiate a set
no
we will run a loop so that let me get
all the
links that we have got in the output
stored in the set and if there is
something repetition it would be
neglected and there will be the single
links there only there will be no
repetition
so for that
for I in
thank you
we will
get a variable text
and inside we will
get the link of the website
foreign
get
and we just pass the hrdf
so we get remove the
links
and now
we will choose our variable
inside we will add
earnings and we'll get it printed
now I will save the file
clear the terminal
and run it
you can see that
all the links have been printed in the
terminal and
if
there is something repetition of the
links that have been neglected and
the unique links have been printed
so now
first we will get it commented and we
will see fun another
now see the div tags and get a div tag
printed here
and get all its contents here also
first we recommend it down
foreign
[Music]
okay
okay here we got all so inside the glass
body we have the div ID equal to root
so here we will get
all the contents from that
and use the ID root
and for that we'll create a variable
with the name root only
root equal to soup
Dot
find
ID
equal to that
root
and now
when we get it
print it
clear the terminal save the file
and run the file
you can see that
all the content that has been stored in
the class with the divided root have
been printed here
so yeah
I think
that makes the most of this tutorial and
if you want to learn more about the web
scripting you can visit the
documentation of beautiful soup and then
you can learn about various elements and
the various objects and you can apply
them on website that permits you to
scrape the data
with that we have come to the end of
this session I hope it was interesting
and informative if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section below
and also do subscribe to our Channel and
stay tuned for more from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here